can you put up a picture of
uh uh by the way does it bother you when
you see pictures or before and after
doesn't know anything okay put pictures
of ethan
when just just just go images just go to
images there's one picture up there that
doesn't bother me at all
look at that stud right there
the hot picture with you with your shirt
off so flexing well there's one there's
one that's pretty good there's other
ones i don't know legs
damn what picture are you most proud of
and what are you most ashamed i don't
want to say ashamed but like i never
want to go back to that i'm not really
ashamed it's just such a bizarre
uh time in my life that i that i just
really uh didn't care about myself at
all you know is that the same human
being
yeah look at that technically i mean
there's parts of my brain that haven't
regenerated you know because the skin is
louis elastic yeah right what a
character in that movie what a freaking
he made it by the way i mean that that
every team needs a guy like that he's a
unifier
you play the role of a unifier in that
movie favorite movie you've ever done
you've done a lot what's your favorite
one that you've done that you're you're
both
most proud of as well as you had the
most fun well
the the most fun is is a tricky one but
the one i'm most proud of for sure as
far as like a movie there's
you know wolf of wall street is really
great but also cold mountain i thought
was like a really really great movie um
the most fun i had was either
wolf of wall street or a movie called
without a paddle which was because
without a pet oh my god i forgot
ah what was it
what song was it but my body is that the
one but yeah i don't see nothing wrong
with it
is that the movie where they're called
oh my god it's a hell of a larry's out
of powder oh it's a hilarious movie me
and abraham ben ruby played brothers and
we're chasing these three dudes around
the forest and seth green yeah it was
awesome
i remember this movie yeah of course
hilarious movie by the way i haven't
seen when did this movie come out early
two thousand that was almost 20 years
ago 2004 there it is yeah and then and
then uh matthew this guy was taking over
hollywood and then gone i don't what
happened to matthew lillard i don't know
he was on a tv show um recently called
that i did a couple episodes of and i'm
blanking on what it's good girls he was
on good girls yeah but
that happens to actors too like we we go
and do a tv show and if you're not
watching the tv show it's as though we
disappeared off the face of the earth
yeah that's that's true um we got to
talk about remember the titans why is
that so important to you i mean the
thing about that was
the team the chemistry the race
relations that it took place in the 60s
what year was this you know when the
whole blm thing was going on with the
protesting i tweeted out i said america
go watch this movie no literally she did
i said go watch this movie today
everybody this movie needs to go viral
and everybody needs to watch it two
years ago it was two years ago yeah
because
the
the story it was so much about what was
going on two years ago you know this
whole thing that you know hey you're
white you're blocking buses no no you
guys are all mixing up you're all going
to sitting together and he takes him and
says hey look what happened to these
soldiers they fought together nobody
cared if you're white and black and then
they came back
and to them racism was gone but they
came to a group of people that racism
still existed and then they're kind of
like oh [ __ ] this is going to be kind of
awkward and that's kind of what's going
on right you're kind of like dude
i don't even think about race i don't
even think about the fact that we have
any different i'm freaking from iran
believe me when 9 11 happened and
everyone's looking i'm in the financial
industry where are you from i'm from
iran did you say you're i was born and
raised in iran you're born and raised in
iran yes
so you're from the same negative was
that that guy that did what he did yeah
kind of but but i'm different very much
right he's like thousand
from the middle east yeah but to the
average guy like wow you kind of look
weird you don't look like normal like us
you know you look like one of these but
about as close as an italian but that's
close to an italian i'm eighteen percent
of attack because you did that test and
you're not french i did the test i found
out someone hooked up with an italian 18
but everything else was pretty accurate
but you know you you see that movie and
you're like oh man dude we are so like
and i feel like it goes back to the same
thing they keep saying it over and over
and over and over and over they're
telling it to you so many times that
like you know naive people are buying
into it like you know what i think i am
no you're not no no no you're not
they've just convinced you you are you
are not that's not your dna that's not
your identity you don't wake up being
like that
it's just been sold to you constantly
right and then eventually like the whole
i read a book years ago it's called the
the genius in all of us and the author
talks about how a
low-income to middle-income family a kid
who was born by the time he turns eight
uh 18 he has heard the word no or been
rejected 600 more times than he's been
encouraged right so a low income middle
income family you've been rejected 600
more times than encouraged right you're
you're you're now accustomed to that
you're now customer suspecting yeah and
then it says like middle to lower upper
upper class it was like a hundred
thousand that you've been discouraged
then encouraged and then it explains
families at upper and above you're
encouraged a hundred more thousand times
than discouraged like it's above and
it's like the kids you know walking
around like this they have some
confidence they go to the schools they
feel pretty good about them so no this
is not for everybody because some of
them are very very critical but the
point is
words have power if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]